We now have the tools to
encrypt data asymmetrically
and to assign data.
I've said these are the
building blocks of QLS.
And now I will prove it to you.
Let's go through the
process of browser users
to set up a TLS-encrypted
connection step by step.
I will still cut a few
corners for simplicity,
but nothing integral
to the concept.
The first step is having the
server send you a certificate.
The certificate
contains the public key
of the server, some
additional information
like the domain the
certificate is for
and the signature by a
certificate authority.
The client checks if the domain
is correct and also checks
if the authority
signature is valid.
As we already explored
earlier, all browsers
have a collection of certificate
authorities including
their public keys saved locally,
so it is trivial to check
if the signature is valid.
Now the client
generates a random key
for symmetric encryption
to be used from here on in.
The browser encrypts the random
key with a server's public key
and sends it over.
This has two benefits.
Symmetric encryption is
much faster, more efficient,
and scales better
to big data compared
to asymmetric encryption.
But more importantly,
the server will only
be able to continue
communicating if it is truly
in possession of the
private key and can
decrypt the new random key.
This effectively validates
the server's identity.
If all of this succeeds,
if your last connection has
successfully been established
and the AGP protocol
can take over, at
this point, you
will get the green
padlock symbol
in your browser's URL bar.